Scott Disick and Bella Thorne get cozy  in can kind of fun  [Music]  things sure seemed to be heating up  between Scott and Bella the 33 year old  reality star was seen having some fun in  the Sun poolside with the 19 year old  actress in can on Tuesday beers Bella  cuddling with her rumored new beau and  smiling from ear to ear after a dip in  the pool fully clothed  pretty soon the pair were first spotted  hanging out earlier this month at catch  restaurant in Los Angeles before taking  their romance overseas et spoke with  Bella in January where she opened up  about dating in Hollywood dating in  Hollywood is literally the worst thing  like it's really crazy because people  make it very difficult like if I'm it  photos out with somebody like  immediately I'm their girlfriend and I  moved in with them too well from the  looks of this kissing pic it sure seems  like these two are a thing this is  fantastic